[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Kai soll
berichter und Marietta Slomka guten
Abend nach seinem Amtsantritt reiste
Bundeskanzler Scholz zuerst nach Japan
und erst danach nach China und jetzt bei
seinem zweiten japanbesuch bringt er
auch noch sein halbes Kabinett mit das
zeigt welches Gewicht er dem asiatischen
Verbündeten beim ist Angela Merkel war
sehr viel häufiger in China als in Japan
das zum Ende ihrer Amtszeit wandte sie
sich stärker Japan zu vielleicht ahnend
dass das mit den Chinesen zunehmend
schwieriger werden würde bei ihrem
letzten Japan besucht 2019 sagte sie
sogar Deutschland und Japan sein im
Grunde fast Nachbarn im Kern liegt nur
Russland zwischen uns damals war das
eine humorige und sehr eigenwillige
Interpretation der Weltkarte heute
rückblickend klingt es fast ahnungsvoll
Elisabeth Schmidt berichtet
ein bisschen Anleitung zur strengen
japanischen Etikette benötigt der
deutsche Gast noch Olaf Scholze wie man
ihn hier nennt ist seit Amtsantritt
bereits zum zweiten Mal nach Tokio
gereist anders als Angela Merkel die
China
sehr geehrter Ministerpräsident lieber
Fumio vielen Dank für den freundlichen
Empfang ist es schön wieder in Tokio zu
sein
furious japanische Besonnenheit trifft
auf Olaf Scholz hanseatische
Gelassenheit die beiden Regierungschefs
machen keinen Hehl daraus sich gut zu
verstehen mit sechs wichtigen Ministern
ist der deutsche Kanzler angereist
Wirtschaft Finanzen innen und
Außenministerin verteidigungs- und
Verkehrsminister auch um von Japan zu
lernen betont die deutsche Delegation
der russische Überfall auf die Ukraine
genauso wie die corona-pandemie zuvor
haben uns schmerzhaft vor Augen geführt
welche Schwierigkeiten es geben kann
wenn zu starke wirtschaftliche
Abhängigkeiten in kritischen Bereichen
bestehen
Japan besitzt sogar ein eigenes
Ministerium für wirtschaftliche
Sicherheit es kümmert sich um eine
vorausschauende Rohstoffpolitik und
stabile Lieferketten deutsche
Unternehmen wissen das zu würdigen
Beispiel Bosch in Yokohama
deutsche Unternehmen schätzen an Japan
hauptsächlich Stabilität politische
Stabilität vertragsstabilität
langfristige Geschäftsbeziehungen und
natürlich profitieren wir auch von einer
hervorragende Infrastruktur Japan wird
für deutsche Unternehmen immer
attraktiver jede zweite deutsche Firma
in Japan arbeitet hier laut
Handelskammer bereits mit einheimischen
Lieferanten zusammen 9% mehr als vor
einem Jahr wir wissen dass es hier nicht
darum geht sich von China abzuwenden
sondern einen Weg zu finden wie man
Risiken anders und besser verteilt da
hat Japan möglicherweise eine Art
Vorreiterrolle übernommen auch beim
Thema militärische Sicherheit wollen
Deutschland und Japan noch enger
zusammenarbeiten weil China immer
häufiger droht Taiwan einzunehmen will
Japan in den kommenden vier Jahren seine
Rüstungsausgaben verdoppeln zeitenwände
Japan fürchtet dass China in Taiwan dem
russischen Beispiel folgen könnte
wir haben nochmals bekräftigt wie
wichtig der Zusammenhalt Gleichgesinnter
Staaten und die Fortführung harter
Sanktionen gegen Russland und eine
starke Unterstützung der Ukraine ist um
die russische Aggression sobald wie
möglich zu beenden
Worte die der Kanzler gerne hört in
politisch unruhigen Zeiten ein Besuch
bei neuen alten Freunden für den sich
Scholz am Ende dann stilsicher auf
japanisch bedankt
die Pleite der kalifornischen Silicon
Valley Bank hat noch mal in Erinnerung
gerufen weil ich große Rolle die
Psychologie spielt die Kunden hatten das
Vertrauen verloren zogen ihr Geld ab und
das war's dann für die Bank ähnliche
geht es gerade der Credit Suisse auch
der laufen die Kunden davon die
Schweizer Finanzaufsicht will nun
offenkundig schnell gegensteuern damit
er nicht etwas größeres ins Rollen kommt
demnach soll die Credit Suisse unter die
Fittiche der anderen Schweizer Großbank
UBS und das ist ein bisschen so als
würde die BaFin die Deutsche Bank dazu
auffordern die Commerzbank zu retten in
der Schweiz bleibt man sich jedenfalls
die Augen Viktoria Kunstmann berechnet
die Situation der taumelnden
großbankkredit Suisse hat sich innerhalb
weniger Tage dramatisch zugespitzt es
geht um ihr Überleben und um den Ruf des
Schweizer Finanzplatzes und so
verhandeln Sie zur Stunde hinter
verschlossenen Türen neuestes Szenario
der größte Konkurrent die UBS soll die
Kredit Suisse übernehmen die Fusion ist
der Wunsch der Schweizer Nationalbank
die Frage ist wie die Credit Suisse
übernommen werden soll man wird in der
Fusion darüber verhandeln welche Teile
denn eigentlich jetzt bei der UBS landen
wie viel Markt macht sie dann in
bestimmten Segmenten hat und davon hängt
halt eben auch ab wie viel gewinnen Sie
in Zukunft machen kann es wird
wahrscheinlich so seine bestimmte Teile
an Dritte verkauft werden damit nicht zu
viel Marktmacht entsteht aber was das
sein wird und wie schlecht oder wie gut
das für die UBS ausgeht da hängt
natürlich viel dran was die staatlichen
Stellen der Schweiz dazu sagen die UBS
steht gut da ist an der Börse etwas 60
Milliarden Franken wert die Credit
Suisse nur noch 7,4 Milliarden die
größte Schweizer Bank soll mit der
zweitgrößten fusionieren zu einer neuen
Schweizer mega-bank das wäre der größte
europäische bankenzusammenschluss seit
der Finanzkrise damals was sie noch den
Musterschülerin brauchte keine
staatlichen Hilfen dann ging sie zu
viele Risiken ein nun laufen der Credit
Suisse seit Monaten die Kunden weg 10
Milliarden Franken so hoch waren die
Abflüsse zuletzt pro Tag Banken haben
viel mit Vertrauen und Glaubwürdigkeit
zu tun und wenn das Vertrauen und die
Glaubwürdigkeit verloren gegangen sind
ist es nicht einfach dass wieder
herzustellen in diesem Prozess steckt
die Credit Suisse jetzt gerade Credit
Suisse hat sicher zu viel riskiert in
den letzten Jahren und das hat man
mittlerweile auch gemerkt dass taumeln
der Schweizer Großbank hat Auswirkungen
auf andere europäische Banken in der
letzten Woche brach der Kurs der Credit
Suisse um 28% ein trotz 50 Milliarden
Franken Finanzspritze der Schweizer
Nationalbank darunter leidet auch der
Kurs der Deutschen Bank
12,77% minus sie und vier weitere große
Geldhäuser haben ihre Geschäfte mit der
Credit Suisse oder deren Wertpapieren
eingeschränkt man hat jetzt Zeit
gewonnen jetzt muss man die Zeit aber
auch nutzen und deswegen muss man jetzt
sehr schnell an einer Lösung arbeiten
damit die Bank so aufgestellt ist dass
sie entweder weiter existieren kann oder
eben dass die Bank in irgendeiner Form
aufgelöst wird damit diese Probleme
nicht dauerhaft den Finanzmarkt und auch
die Reputation der Schweiz als Bankplatz
belasten bis Sonntagabend wird es wohl
eine Einigung geben bevor die Börsen am
Montag wieder öffnen bevor die Credit
Suisse den guten Ruf des Schweizer
Bankenwesens aufs Spiel setzt
und jetzt die Nachrichten von Heinz Wolf
Russland und die Ukraine haben sich auf
eine Verlängerung des getreideabkommens
geeinigt das sonst morgen ausgelaufen
wäre das gaben die UN und der türkische
Präsident Erdogan bekannt das Abkommen
regelt die Freigabe der ukrainischen
Häfen und einen Korridor im Schwarzen
Meer für Getreideexporte für wie lange
die neue Vereinbarung gelten soll ist
unklar für 120 Tage war die Forderung
der Ukraine nur 60 Tage die Position
Russlands
der russische Präsident Putin ist heute
auf die Halbinsel Krem gereist zum 9
jahrestag der Annexion er besuchte dort
laut russischem Staatsfernsehen eine
Kunstschule und ein Kinderzentrum nach
einer internationalen nicht anerkannten
Volksabstimmung 2014 hatte Putin das
Gebiet in die Russische Föderation
eingegliedert der Annexion wird
international als Völkerrechtsbruch
verurteilt
Bundesnetzagentur Schiff Müller rechnet
mit sinkenden Gaspreisen für Verbraucher
erst in einigen Monaten müller sagte der
Rheinischen Post bis die Senkung der
Großhandelspreise auch bei den
Haushaltskunden ankomme dürfte es noch
sechs bis zwölf Monate dauern das liege
vor allem an Vertragslaufzeiten und
Einkaufsstrategien
die Bundestagsfraktion der Grünen heilt
den Kohleausstieg auch im Osten
Deutschlands nicht erst für 28 sondern
bereits für 2030 an so wie in
Nordrhein-Westfalen in eine Vorlage für
die Fraktionsklausur in der kommenden
Woche heißt es dass sein notwendig um
die Klimaziele zu erreichen in dem
betroffenen Bundesländern brannten Burg
Sachsen und Sachsen-Anhalt wird ein
früherer Ausstieg kritisch gesehen und
auch bei den
ampelkoalitionspartnern gibt es
Widerspruch
die Linken Bundestagsabgeordnete Sahra
Wagenknecht will bis Ende des Jahres
entscheiden ob Sie eine neue
parteigrundet das sagte sie gegenüber
ZDF heute de dabei spiele eine Rolle ob
Sie dazu die gesundheitliche Kraft habe
als one woman Show können Sie das nicht
Sahra Wagenknecht hatte angekündigt
nicht mehr für die Linke zu kandidieren
auch weil sie in ihrer Partei mit ihrem
Positionen zum Ukraine Krieg aneckte das
ganze Interview finden sie auf ZDF
heute.de und in unserer ZDF heute App
Serbien und Kosovo verhandeln über ein
neues Abkommen dass die schwierigen
gegenseitigen Beziehungen regeln soll
das Kosovo hatte sich 2008 für
unabhängig erklärt Serbien erkennt das
nicht an heute gab es unter
eu-vermittlung ein Spitzengespräch von
Serbiens Präsident Vucic und dem
kosovarischen Ministerpräsidenten Kurti
bei dem Abkommen geht es zum einen um
die Eigenstaatlichkeit des Kosovo und
zum anderen um die Rechte der serbischen
Volksgruppe im Kosovo
es mag auch daran liegen dass eine neu
gebaute Replik keine Geschichte atmet
beim Besuch des eher sterilen Berliner
Stadtschlosses 2.0 fällt es jedenfalls
eher schwer sich zu erinnern welch
dramatisch Ereignisse sich hier einst
zutrauen die bauliche Restauration
betrifft schließlich genau jeden Platz
auf dem die erste deutsche Revolution
tobte im wilden märz 1848 der König von
Preußen musste sogar auf dem Balkon
erscheinen und vor den Aufständischen
seinen Hut ziehen mit diesem ersten
demokratieversuch was dann aber auch
sehr schnell wieder vorbei das
preußische her war stärker die
revolutionäre zu uneins wie man in
Berlin heute an diese Ereignisse
erinnerte berichtet Stefan Merseburger
der König schießt auf sein Volk auf die
Barrikaden
Berlin im revolutionsfieber eine
szenische Stadtführung erinnert an 1848
als das Volk für mehr Rechte und
Freiheit auf die Straße ging die
deutschen stehen ein erstes Mal auf
gegen Militär und
polizeimonarchien gegen Despotismus und
zwar tausende zehntausende wären sich
ein allererstes mal und sind gar nicht
die Untertanen die braven die die
deutschen ansonsten wir die wir so gerne
manchmal gewesen sind unter den
umsturzlern sind auch Frauen
Feministinnen erstaunlich modern Luis
Essen zum Beispiel sie trägt Hosen
raucht Zigarren und schreibt über
Emanzipation alles ziemlich unerhört
damals via App wird sie kurz lebendig
müssen wir gegen die Obrigkeit erkämpfen
müsst ihr das auch noch entschuldigt
mich ich muss zurück auf die Barrikaden
auch der Bundespräsident will die 48er
heute würdigen er kommt deshalb nicht
auf aber immerhin vor die Barrikade
Persönlichkeiten der Geist der Freiheit
der war in der Welt und dieser Geist der
Freiheit konnte nicht mehr erstickt
werden durch Obrigkeiten und Diktatur
vor 175 Jahren ziehen die Berliner vor
das Schloss das Militär schlägt den
Aufstand blutig nieder der König von
Preußen Friedrich Wilhelm der vierte
gibt den Befehl
das preußische Militär war angehalten
mit äußerster Brutalität vorzugehen das
wurde trainiert es ist ein Gemetzel ein
Massaker geworden mit unglaublichen
Schrecklichkeiten doch die demokratische
Bewegung macht weiter in der Frankfurter
Paulskirche entsteht ein Parlament dass
eine Verfassung erarbeitet eine
Delegation reist 1849 nach Berlin und
versucht den Preußen König zu einer
konstitutionellen Monarchie zu bewegen
Friedrich Wilhelm lehnt ab die
Revolution scheitert
er sieht sich in ganz unmittelbaren
Sinne als einen Herrscher der von Gott
eingesetzt ist und
wehrt sich schon zuvor mit mit allem
gegen Verfassung und Parlament gegen
jedes demokratische Recht
gedenken heute auch auf dem Friedhof der
März gefallenen mehr als 250 Menschen
starben der Jüngste war 15 11 Frauen
waren unter den 48ern sie ließen ihr
Leben im Kampf für Gleichberechtigung
und Demokratie für die Freiheit
und jetzt die Lottozahlen dieses
samstags sie lauten wie immer ohne
Gewähr 3 5 9 23 27 44 Superzahl 9
weitere Gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto.zdf.de und im ZDF Text auf Seite
die Wetteraussichten morgen scheint im
Osten am Vormittag noch häufig die Sonne
sonst überwiegen die Wolken und es gibt
Schauer und Gewitter die Temperatur
steigt auf Werte von 11 bis 18 Grad am
Montag zieht der Regen nach Osten ab am
Dienstag ist das meist freundlich am
Mittwoch kommt neuer Regen auf mit 9 bis
19 Grad ist es sehr mild
das war es von uns weiter geht es im
Aktuellen Sportstudio und danach ging
0.25 gibt es da die nächste heute
Express auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]